استقبال كبير من اهالي عنيزه وايضا من
اهالي منطقه القصيم وايضا من السياح سواء
السعوديين او حتى الخليجيين على السياحه
الريفيه في منطقه القصيم التي تتميز
بمزارعها الكبيره امير منطقه القصيم قبل
ايام عقد اجتماعا للجنه السياحيه في
المنطقه لتعزيز السياحه الريفيه في مستقبل
الايام انضم الان الاستاذ ابراهيم طويرب
عبد الله احد المستثمرين في القطاع
السياحه الريفيه ابو عبد الله اولا خلينا
نتكلم عن الاقبال انت يمكن لك سنه وشوي
فاتح المزرعه هذه كيف شكل الاقبال حتى
الان اهله والله وسهلا بكم اولا وشرفتونا
الاقبال جدا جميل يعني عدد كبير من داخل
منطقه القصيم ومن خارج المنطقه وعلى مستوى
الدول الخليج تتوسع ما شاء الله كل شوي
قاعده تتوسع بسبب الاقبال الكبير على
المزرعه الحمد لله الان في توسع وفي اقبال
ما شاء الله كبير من دول الخليج على
السياحه الريفيه انت ما شاء الله خالد زي
ما انتم شايفين البنوت الصغيره هذه قاعد
تحلب البقره طبعا هذه بنت ابو عبد الله
ملوكه ملاك طبعا انت بناتك واولادك شغالين
معك في المزرعه نعم نعم هم شغالين معي
بالمزرعه وساكن انا اصلا بالمزرعه ما شاء
الله متعلمين مع الزراعه والحال والعنايه
بالجميع الحيوانات داخل المزرعه كيف تشوف
ردود فعل الناس لما يجون تشوفون عائلتك
معاك شغاله وقاعد تحاول يعني تعلمهم مثل
هذه المهن الاصيله والقديمه الصحيحه اعجاب
الكثير من الزوار وان شلون
بالزراعه وشلون العيال ما شاء الله بالدخل
المزرعه متعاونين يعني هذه حياتنا اول
يعني ما في هذا البنوته شو اسمها
ما شاء الله وهذا اللي معها طبعا حبيبتها
حبيبتها هالله هالله طبعا خالد ايضا
المزرعه هنا تقدم وجبات يعني اكل للزوار
طبعا قبل رمضان في افطار صباحي واليوم في
رمضان انتم عندكم افطار افطار رمضان الان
نجهزه ونستقبل وكل شيء يجهز قدامهم ينشور
وسمبوسه وخبز بيتزا كله موجود يعني انت
الحين تقدم تجربه زراعيه رائعه للزوار
تجربه يشوفون الحيوانات يشوفون الاشجار
يخطفون الفواكه والثمار وايضا تقدم لهم
يعني وجبه غذائيه ريفيه نعم وجبه غذائيه
ريفيه واللي اجمل من كذا انه كل شيء يصلح
قدامك وتشوفه قدامك
ابو عبد الله نعم
في الافطار اليوم بنقدم اللي هو الشوربه
ونقدم
السمبوسه
شخص اكيد يحب الاكل فلازم تاخذ راحتك
بالوصف وهو صايم بعد فنبى نجوع الزياده
فاخذ راحتك بالوصف
طبعا من الفرن على طول على الطاوله على
الزبون الفطيس الزعتر السمبوسه تاوا
الشوربه الفول القهوه الشاه البدوع يعني
قدم لك فطور وبايدك تط هاي جره الفول وراك
انت حولت شغفك بالطبخ طبعا ان شاء الله
تنفور يا خالد وراي فول مدمس فول جره نعم
خالد زي ما انت شايف يعني يا ابو عبد الله
قصه ملهمه وناجحه حول شغفه والزراعه الى
مكان
ممكن ممكن
يقيم يوم يومين فيها ولا شلون
المزرعه الله يحييه والله يشرفنا واعز من
يجينا والله خلاص يا خالد تعال انت بس
امورك طيبه
لا طبعا هي متاحه
للزوار يحجزون عن طريق التليفون الواتساب
ويجون يستمتعون بالاجواء بكل اريحيه